digamos que tengo una curva ce verdad y
a esta curva se la vamos a parametrizar
como digamos nuestra coordenada x que en
realidad va a ser una función que
depende del tiempo y también nuestra
coordenada y será una función que
depende del tiempo entonces esta curva
está contenida en el plano verdad en r2
y vamos a considerar valores del tiempo
digamos t que sean mayores o iguales que
a y menores o iguales que ve muy bien
entonces lo que vamos a hacer ahora es
tratar de graficar lo vamos a tratar de
hacer una un esbozo de una gráfica de
cómo sería esta curva entonces aquí
tenemos nuestros ejes aquí tenemos el
eje horizontal que es el eje x el eje
vertical que es el eje y y podríamos
pintar nuestra curva que quizás se vea
algo así verdad entonces por ejemplo
aquí aquí tendríamos el punto final que
corresponde a cuando te es igual a b y
entonces este punto tiene coordenadas x
debe coma y debe y debe y por ejemplo
entonces este primer punto de aquí
seguiría cuando te vale a verdad y
tendría coordenadas x de a coma idea y
entonces el resto de estos puntos
corresponden a los distintos valores de
t entre a y b verdad para estas
funciones x y ye muy bien entonces ya
hemos visto esto antes por supuesto es
digamos la forma común de parametrizar
una curva usando 22 funciones
parametrizados verdad con el parámetro
de ahora lo que quiero hacer es
describir esta misma curva usando una
función de valores vectoriales verdad
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es tomar
una función de valores vectoriales
digamos vamos a tomarnos r&r y le voy a
poner una flechita arriba para que se
indique claramente que es una función
que toma valores vectoriales y de hecho
en algunos libros de texto en vez de
usar
digamos arriba del aire utilizarían
negritas verdad pero pues sería muy
difícil poner yo en este en estos
dibujos negritas verdad entonces en
nosotros sólo para distinguir las
funciones vectoriales vamos a poner una
flechita arriba y sólo para que quede
muy claro esto de aquí va a depender por
supuesto del parámetro t que es
podríamos pensar que es el tiempo verdad
y todos estos de aquí todos estos
valores que puede tomar esta función son
vectores de posición
estos son vectores aquí está ese no se
ve muy bien son vectores de posición muy
bien y voy a aclarar en unos segundos a
qué se refiere esto de los vectores de
posición de hecho lo voy a aclarar
porque a veces algunas personas
consideran por ejemplo este vector que
es el mismo que este vector verdad
digamos que para estas personas que
consideran estos dos vectores como
vectores equivalentes
no importa dónde empiezan y donde
terminan en tanto tengan la misma
magnitud y dirección muy bien entonces
para nosotros digamos en este caso
cuando consideramos vectores de posición
todos los vectores comenzarán en el
origen verdad en el origen de
coordenadas y terminarán en este punto
por ejemplo del espacio en donde estemos
trabajando verdad entonces por ejemplo
nosotros podríamos poner este vector de
posición de esta forma comienza en el
origen y termina en el punto del espacio
que nos interesa verdad entonces de esta
misma idea se puede aplicar por ejemplo
cuando estamos hablando de tres
dimensiones de cuatro dimensiones o
incluso de n dimensiones verdad así que
así es como consideramos a esta función
r de t como una función de posiciones de
valores vectoriales entonces voy a
seguir usando este color verde este rd
te lo vamos a poder escribir de la
siguiente forma va a ser x dt que
multiplica a nuestro vector unitario
en horizontal es decir en la dirección
del eje x
dt que multiplica al vector unitario
pero en la dirección vertical verdad es
decir en la dirección del eje y y por
supuesto que si uno tuviera por ejemplo
una tercera dimensión verdad podríamos
poner más z que depende del tiempo por
el vector unitario en la dirección del
eje z pero bueno aquí solo estamos
trabajando en r2 es decir en el plano
así que nos vamos a quedar hasta aquí y
por supuesto hay que poner que nuestro t
nuestro parámetro t se encuentra entre
los valores que son todos los valores
que se encuentran entre a y entre b muy
bien entonces vamos a tratar de dibujar
esto mismo en otra digamos en otra
gráfica para que se vea claramente que
en realidad estamos expresando la misma
curva es exactamente la misma curva
entonces aquí está el eje x aquí está el
eje de verdad
ahora por ejemplo pensemos en el punto
rda vamos a hacerlo por aquí vamos a ver
quién sería rda
bueno pues rda sería simplemente
sustituir en vez de poner te vamos a
poner a entonces sería x de a que
multiplica nuestro vector unitario y
verdad que va en la dirección horizontal
más de a por el vector unitario en la
dirección vertical verdad entonces por
ejemplo esto en nuestra primera imagen
por ejemplo aquí está nuestra coordenada
x de a esto sería ideal y por ejemplo
podríamos pensar que este es nuestro
vector unitario y y este es nuestro
vector unitario jota verdad entonces así
que pensemos que es lo que está
ocurriendo este vector y lo estamos
estirando hasta este punto que tiene
digamos magnitud x sea verdad
simplemente estamos estirando el vector
unitario y hasta llegar a este punto
y de hecho lo mismo ocurriría con el
vector j estaríamos estirando lo hasta
llegar a este punto con magnitud idea
muy bien
lo que ocurriría en nuestro siguiente
caso es que tendríamos nuestro vector de
posición es decir comienza en el origen
verdad y tiene esas dos componentes aquí
estaría más o menos el x de a veces
nuestro vector y y por acá estaría
nuestra nuestro vector que corresponde a
llegue a por el vector j verdad entonces
este vector de aquí es r de a es r de a
muy bien entonces qué pasaría por
ejemplo si ahora tomamos un valor un
poco más grande que a por ejemplo qué
pasaría si tomamos ere evaluado en a más
h bueno pues esto nuevamente sería x de
a más h por el vector unitario y más
idea más h por el vector unitario jota y
pues básicamente lo único que está
ocurriendo es que estamos dejando
avanzar un poco nuestro parámetro de
verdad entonces puede ser que ahora
estemos colocados en este punto de aquí
verdad entonces lo que ocurre lo que
ocurre es que vamos a tener nuestro
vector que estaría localizado más o
menos así verdad
siguiendo la imagen de esta curva
estaría más o menos localizado aquí y
este vector de aquí sería r evaluado lo
va a poner mejor arriba este vector de
aquí sería el vector r evaluado en
h verdad entonces así podemos notar que
a medida que aumentamos el parámetro t
lo único que va ocurriendo es que
estamos recorriendo esta misma curva
pero cada uno de estos puntos lo estamos
representando con un vector es decir una
flecha que va del origen al punto del
espacio por eso es que es un vector de
posición entonces más o menos esta curva
se vería más o menos así cuando lo
estamos recorriendo quizás voy a voy a
hacerlo un poquito mejor
así y que corresponde a más o menos la
misma imagen que tenemos acá a verdad
entonces por ejemplo este último punto
correspondería al vector que va de este
punto a este otro verdad
un poquito
un poquito distinto verdad lo voy a
hacer voy a hacerlo un poco menos grueso
para que se vea claro entonces aquí
tendríamos nuestra flecha verdad nuestro
vector
y lo tenemos este sería rdb éste sería r
debe que sería el último punto en
nuestra curva así que espero que no te
es que estos vectores de posición lo
único que están haciendo es especificar
los mismos puntos de esta curva original
que parametrizados con las funciones x
de t 7 y esto sólo lo hago como un
pequeño repaso porque ahora nos vamos a
adentrar en la idea de lo que es derivar
una función de valores vectoriales pero
eso lo haré en el próximo vídeo